[Musica]
le immagini sono lo strumento potente
hanno il potere di cambiare la
percezione che abbiamo delle cose e se
usate nel modo sbagliato possono avere
conseguenze devastanti
faccio la fotografa ed immagini ne so
qual cosina ho iniziato la mia carriera
fotografica nella fotografia di moda
dopo circa tre anni vivevo a new york
all'epoca un giorno mentre mi guardavo
allo specchio mi sono sentita pensare
vorrei tanto potermi photoshoppare la
faccia e lì ho capito che c'era un
problema
vedete oggi siamo costantemente
bombardati da immagini se si vive in una
città come londra parigi new york milano
solo uscendo di casa siamo esposti a
migliaia di immagini per non parlare di
quelle che poi vediamo sui social e se
queste immagini ritraggono solo donne e
uomini perfetti inevitabilmente su con
cemento iniziamo a sentirci inadeguati
io queste immagini perfette le creavo e
so cosa ci sta dietro
ma una persona normale non ne ho idea
non sanno che per creare una di queste
immagini serve una modella che a tratti
fisici che appartengono a meno del 2 per
cento della popolazione è solitamente a
tra i 14 ei 19 anni non sanno che la
ragazza arriva sul set a 2 ore in make
up
c'è un team di quattro cinque persone
che sistema ogni singolo dettaglio e poi
tutta la parte di post produzione e alla
fine della giornata
la ragazza nella foto non assomiglia più
alla ragazza nella foto ma noi guardiamo
la ragazza nella foto pensando perché
non le assomiglio quando sfogliamo una
rivista di moda questo e loop che scatta
nella testa di una donna da una perfetta
donna perfetta
io non sono perfetta sono brutta faccio
schifo non sono abbastanza
è un processo lineare quando entriamo in
questo loop la nostra autostima ci va
sotto i piedi quando la nostra autostima
e bassa non riusciamo a realizzarci
perché non crediamo più nelle nostre
capacità
io che so benissimo cosa ci sta dietro
queste immagini ne rimango influenzata
quindi pensate l'effetto che può avere
su una ragazzina adolescente
nella fase più delicata del suo sviluppo
quello che ancora meno persone sanno è
che questo meccanismo ha creato ad hoc
dall industria della moda della bellezza
della chirurgia estetica per farci star
male per farci sentire insicuri così da
farci comprare più prodotti con la
promessa di farci diventare più belli
una volta capite queste dinamiche con la
consapevolezza che il mio lavoro
contribuiva a creare quegli standard di
bellezza irreali e irraggiungibili che
facevano star male alle donne
ho avuto una crisi di coscienza e ho
deciso di cambiare rotta
lasciandovi il mondo della moda alle
spalle nel ottobre 2015
ho iniziato un progetto personale questo
beauty ho iniziato a viaggiare in
solitaria per intervistare e fotografare
donne di tutti i giorni per chiedere a
loro
cos'era bellezza sono state in etiopia
marocco giappone tanzania vietnam hong
kong e molti molti altri posti
e guarda caso quando chiedevo cos'era
bellezza le donne mi rispondevano sempre
con risposte che non aveva niente a che
fare con l'aspetto fisico in poco tempo
sono passata dalla fotografia di moda
quella di viaggio e ho iniziato ad usare
instagram creavo delle foto fiabesche
che facevano sognare un po instagram è
diventato parte integrante del mio
lavoro sviluppato un buon seguito sui
social e sono diventata un influencer ma
col tempo ho notato che le stesse
dinamiche che mi avevano fatto scappare
dal mondo della moda adesso si stavano
innescando anche su instagram
solo che qui invece di parlare di
standard di bellezza irreali
parliamo di standard di vita irreali
oggi sui social ci sono tantissimi
quanto inquieto più comunemente chiamati
influencer che come volte faccio io
possano foto patinate che mostrano vite
da sogno quando apriamo instagram
siamo bombardati da immagini di gente
seduta a bordo piscina ma che con
colazione sfarzosissima anche poi non
vengono mangiate gente in accappatoio
bianco l'nh hotel lussuosi gente sempre
dall aspetto impeccabile e sempre
vestita all'amore
sempre in viaggio di un posto stupendo
ma quella non è vita vera questi queste
foto non rappresentano momenti della
nostra vita
noi la nostra vita la fermiamo per
creare questi momenti sono delle
immagini sinistra che se una persona
apre vede tutto questo immagino questa
ragazza una vita stupenda e sempre in
vacanza ai tropici
in realtà le foto ingannano perché tutte
queste foto sono state scattate nello
stesso giorno con diversi cambi d'abito
nello stesso resort non erano in vacanza
ero lì appositamente per creare queste
immagini per il resort non stavo facendo
una vacanza stavo lavorarlo vedete è
molto facile falsificare il proprio
stile di vita sui social
io ho fatto parte del problema per
parecchio tempo ma quando mi sono resa
conto dell'effetto che le mie immagini
potevano avere sulla gente
ho avuto la crisi di coscienza numero 2
non mi sentivo più bene a fare quello
che stavo facendo
ho raccolto tutto il coraggio che avevo
e ho deciso di dire la verità di essere
onesta ho iniziato a spiegare a chi mi
seguiva che le mie foto erano
costruzioni e non rappresentavano la mia
vita minimamente il che mi ha portato
una buona dose di criticismo parecchi
haters ma io ho seguito sia raddoppiato
e ho ricevuto migliaia di messaggi di
persone che mi ringraziavano per essere
stata onesta per avergli fatto vedere le
cose in un modo diverso
il problema che oggi la maggior parte
degli influenze rock on the creator
chiamateli come volete che producono
questo stesso tipo di foto le spacciano
per vita vera dicono mi sono svegliato
così magari al pari tra la foto è ben
diversa e l'utente ignaro si ritrova a
emulare tutta questa perfezione perché
si trova sotto pressione e possa
immagini sempre più artificiali sui
social ormai postiamo dei ritagli della
nostra vita selezionati con cura i tagli
che rappresentano solo il meglio del
meglio e questo innesca il solito
meccanismo di cui vi ho parlato prima
vita perfetta vita perfetta
la mia vita non è perfetta io non sono
perfetto faccio schifo non sono
abbastanza e autostima depressione
abbiamo creato un mondo dove la falsità
e costantemente venduta come vita vera
distorcendo la percezione collettiva che
abbiamo della realtà e facendo dei danni
enormi alle nostre menti e alla nostra
autostima senza che nemmeno ce ne
accorgiamo
pensate al fatto che oggi i nuovi
telefoni hanno già incorporata nella
telecamera il filtro che ci liscia la
pelle è terrificante
è gravissimo tutte queste manie di
perfezione ci stanno facendo dimenticare
cosa vuol dire davvero essere umani
siamo ormai costantemente sotto
pressione pressione di essere perfetti
belli seguiti connessi di successo e
felici ma la perfezione non esiste e
anemica della felicità ora che il mondo
è a portata di click tutti vogliamo
apparire tutti vogliamo essere visti
ascoltati validati anche chi non ha
niente da dire o da far vedere
vi ricordate chi eravate prima dei
social come passavate il vostro tempo
quando non c'era da preoccuparsi di
numeri di likes di followers cosa
condivideva te con gli altri e come e
perché
dieci anni dopo l'introduzione dei
social ci ritroviamo ad affrontare un
picco di problemi di salute mentale e la
dipendenza dai nostri device è diventata
un problema reale i risultati di diverse
indagini dimostrano che gli effetti
collaterali che i social stanno causando
sulle nostre menti sono tanti e
apparentemente instagram è la
piattaforma peggiore soprattutto per i
giovani e instagram è fatta di immagini
immagini di moda di viaggio di lifestyle
di fitness di cibo tutti bellissimi
tutti felicissimi tutto fighissimo ma
secondo molti studi queste immagini
influenzano negativamente il sonno
l'immagine del corpo d'autostima
scatenano sentimenti di inadeguatezza a
fumo ho avuto paura di essere tagliati
fuori
ansia e depressione che nei casi più
estremi ma esistenti può portare al
suicidio
i teenager sono ovviamente più a rischio
ma la cosa influenza anche noi
morale della favola dopo dieci anni
siamo tutti meno felici vogliamo
apparire sempre di più e siamo sempre
più dipendenti dai social guarda caso
come l'industria della moda ci fa
sentire inadeguati per farci comprare
più prodotti i social sono disegnati
appositamente per farci diventare social
addicted dipendenti
pensate alle notifiche rosse quanto vi
da fastidio lasciarle lì non aprire quel
messaggio non cliccare su quella
modifica quiroga dentro no ogni mi piace
una scarica di dopamina una dose di
gratificazione istantanea che ci fa
stare bene
lì per lì ma è tutto studiato apposta
per farci stare online e cliccare di più
perché ogni clic genera profitto e oggi
tutto si basa sul profitto
siamo sempre più serrati dai soldi
dall'accumulazione di beni materiali
tutto questo ci distrae facendoci
dimenticare quello che conta davvero
chi siamo la nostra interiorità la vita
non è fatta solo di business marketing
la società moderna ci spinge verso
quella direzione e valorizza sempre di
più gli aspetti peggiori dell'uomo
egoismo superficialità narcisismo è una
società egoistica disconnessa
ossessionata dall immagine e dipendente
dalle dosi dopamina rilasciate dai cuori
pollici alzati che ormai fanno parte
integrante della nostra vita sempre più
digitale e disumanizzata qui mi rivolgo
soprattutto la mia generazione millenial
ma anche i più giovani e magari anche a
chi è più grande di me
siamo sempre più connessi ma sempre più
disconnessi da noi stessi e dalle
persone a cui vogliamo bene
usciamo a cena con gli amici e stiamo
tutto il tempo al telefono il tuo
bambino piangere gli dà in mano un
tablet per distrarlo i social hanno
cambiato il modo in cui comunichiamo e
le relazioni umane
vi ricordate quando per sapere come
stava un amico bisognava chiamarlo o
andare a trovarlo ma oggi apre facebook
in strane di una foto metti un mi piace
e la conversazione non avviene più non
ci chiamiamo più comunichiamo tramite
whatsapp messenger ci scambiamo tweets
commenti mi piace ma siamo sempre meno
capaci di parlarci come vi sentite
quando un vostro cliente ignora
e mail o la persona che state
frequentando non risponde al vostro
messaggio per giorni quelle dannate
spunte blu fanno male innescano quella
voce che ti dice non sono abbastanza
ormai invece di affrontare le nostre
emozioni ci confrontiamo in discussione
e di comportarci in discussioni e
prenderci le nostre responsabilità
ignoriamo il messaggio ci nascondiamo
dietro lo schermo isolandoci sempre di
più diventando sempre di più soli al di
là di esso scollando più a lungo per
riempire il vuoto della nostra
solitudine ma riempiendoci sempre di più
la testa di cose che ci fanno star male
e si fa mascherare l'idea
irraggiungibili
ok vi o depressi abbastanza però per
fortuna i social non sono solo male non
portano solo cose brutte grazie ai
social
oggi possiamo raggiungere cose che fino
a qualche anno fa erano completamente
impensabili possiamo rimanere in
contatto con persone dall'altra parte
del mondo non sono insomma il problema è
il modo in cui li usiamo che fa la
differenza
quindi come curarsi da questo malessere
moderno con la verità prendendo
consapevolezza non credete a tutto
quello che vedete immagini costruite
photoshoppate influencer con numeri di
followers pompati e popolarità
inflazionata news
la realtà è ormai troppo facile da
manipolare sviluppato un senso critico e
chiedetemi sempre cosa è vero e cosa no
ascoltiamoci non è facile ma bisogna
imparare a guardarsi dentro essere
onesti con se stessi
chiedetevi sempre in che valori credo
cosa ho da offrire
questa cosa mi fa stare bene e se la
risposta è no bisogna eliminarlo se ci
sentiamo male scorrendo sui nostri feed
mettiamo di guardare di seguire le
persone che possano cose che ci fanno
star male e pubblicità parte abbiamo
ancora il potere di decidere di che
contenuti nutrirci de condizioniamo il
pensiero quello che pensiamo ha
influenzato dal mondo esterno dalle
nostre famiglie dai nostri amici dei
social media per trovare la propria voce
per urlare la nostra voce dobbiamo
spegnere tutte le all
3 per capire chi siamo cosa vogliamo
veramente cosa ci interessa davvero
dobbiamo sbattersene del giudizio altrui
possiamo passiamo meno tempo online a
guardare cosa fanno gli altri e iniziamo
a pensare con la nostra testa solo così
possiamo vivere la nostra verità e
condividere cose che ci rappresentano
veramente connettiamoci alle persone con
umanità bisogna dare il giusto valore
alle persone che conosciamo offline sono
loro che contano veramente sempre
comportarsi con rispetto a online
scrivere quel commento di cattiveria
gratuita o ignorare quel messaggio sono
gesti codardi facili presi alla leggera
ma il dolore che possono provocare e le
insicurezze che possono scaturire
nell'altra persona possono essere enormi
bisogna sempre ricordarsi che anche se
abbiamo uno schermo di mezzo dall'altra
parte dello schermo c'è un umano una
persona fatta di sentimenti emozioni e
paure
mostriamoci per chi siamo veramente
dovremmo essere noi stessi sia online
che offline sempre postando le nostre
imperfezioni le nostre vulnerabilità
mostrando i nostri successi ma
soprattutto i nostri fallimenti sono
quelli che si vendono umani non può
andare sempre tutto bene
nell'ultimo anno ho capito che quel che
mi faceva stare bene davvero non erano
le foto patinate di vite da sogno o gli
hotel di lusso ma era la connessione con
la gente che incontrava nei miei viaggi
era l'umanità che scorreva tra di noi
il poter raccontare le loro storie mi
sono chiesta ripetutamente allo
sfinimento in che valore credo
cosa ho da offrire cosa mi fa star bene
e adesso lavoro con ing principalmente
su progetti che mi fanno star bene mi
fanno sentire utile e sono in linea con
i miei valori e dopo anni di crisi
mistiche e strade sbagliate penso forse
di essere su quella giusta e sto
finalmente vivendo la mia verità offline
e online
l'onestà e la verità sono la chiave per
liberarsi dalla prigione digitale di
falsità che ci siamo costruiti e oggi
più che mai il mondo ha un disperato
bisogno
verità prendiamo quella strada perché
l'altra porta solo verso la
disumanizzazione
ascoltatevi siate voi stessi
dite la verità e mostratevi sempre per
quello che siete veramente umani
stupendamente e imperfettamente umani
grazie
[Musica]